[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué tal muy buenas espero que estéis muy
bien por ahí allá donde me estáis viendo
pues la verdad que vengo entusiasmado y
os voy a explicar por qué en los últimos
siete días tres noticias la primera hace
aproximadamente una semana se presenta
el primer coche europeo con nivel 3 de
conducción autónoma ahora vamos a ver
qué es eso hace solamente unos 7 días
más o menos hace 48 horas vengo de
probar un coche eléctrico que con ayudas
con subvenciones eso sí cuesta nueve mil
euros y hace escasas horas se estrenaba
un vídeo que os presentaba el proyecto
de un emprendedor español que presenta
un vehículo súper deportivo eléctrico
aquí hecho en españa y esto ha ocurrido
solamente estas tres noticias en los
últimos siete días
así que ese titular de la charla de hoy
de la industria de automóvil va a
cambiar más en los próximos diez años ya
estamos en ese cambio que en los pasados
100 no es un lema sin más un lema vacío
es que realmente está ocurriendo pero
tenemos que empezar
justamente yéndonos a hace 100 años y
hace 100 años qué es lo que pasó
bueno pues pasó que encontramos una
manera de encontrar valga la redundancia
atajos para acelerar nos como sociedad
como civilización incluso
hemos vivido en la era del petróleo si
os fijáis y nos ponemos a pensar un
poquito en toda esta evolución
tecnológica tan rápida que hemos tenido
en los últimos 100 años solamente se
puede explicar desde el punto de vista
de utilizar muchísima energía detrás de
la revolución científica tecnológica del
conocimiento hay montones y montones de
energía de dónde sale esa energía pues
debajo de tierra se llama petróleo así
que en los últimos 100 años hemos vivido
en la era del petróleo y asociada a la
era del petróleo la era del automóvil
esto es muy importante tenerlo en cuenta
porque no es solamente el automóvil el
que genera un problema medioambiental
importante sino es nuestra adicción al
consumo energético eso nos ha dado un
nivel de proyección y de conocimiento
que ahora nos permite pasar a la
siguiente fase y es justamente en ese
momento en el que estamos pero recordad
que el petróleo no solamente mueve los
coches mueve la minería también mueve la
ropa que llevamos puesta incluso hay
petróleo en los medicamentos que tomamos
contra la ansiedad el petróleo está en
todas partes y es un cohete al que nos
hemos subido y del que ahora nos tenemos
que bajar juntos justamente y subirnos a
algo que nos permita seguir volando y de
eso va esta charla de cómo la industria
del automóvil puede
a este cambio así que para hablar del
cambio me vais a permitir que empiece
hablando de caballos
y los caballos que tienen que ver con la
industria del automóvil bueno pues que
justamente hace 100 años cuando nos
movíamos por ahí lo hacíamos todavía a
caballo los primeros coches justamente
se estaban empezando a desarrollar los
primeros coches se estaban empezando a
fabricar pero el caballo era nuestro
automóvil de hace 100 años y como
siempre ocurre cuando los seres humanos
nos empezamos a acumular en masa
empezaron los problemas con los caballos
cuáles son los problemas bueno pues
fijaos estas fotos que os voy a enseñar
ahora probablemente muchos de vosotros
las hayáis visto pero me van a dar pie a
contaros cosas que espero que sean muy
interesantes esta es una foto de la
quinta avenida de nueva york en el año
1900 y que se utiliza mucho para
promover el automóvil eléctrico aquí lo
que vemos es una calle atestada de gente
y atestada de carruajes con caballos y
esos circulitos que hay ahí son para
enseñar los automóviles que se estaban
moviendo en ese momento nueva york
londres parís chicago las grandes
ciudades del mundo empezaban a tener un
problema provocado por los caballos cuál
era el problema pues parece mentira pero
la cantidad ingente de excrementos de
bonn y gas que iban soltando por las
calles hasta tal punto que empezó a ser
un problema de salud público
por la acumulación de caballos de
carruajes dentro de las ciudades
acumulación de personas acumulación de
medios de locomoción problemas de
contaminación ambiental o suena los
problemas que tenemos hoy en día en las
ciudades de contaminación ambiental ya
estaban en esos tiempos empezaban a
estar solo que aquí eran mucho más
visibles los podíamos pisar y por
supuesto leer también la siguiente
imagen es de 13 años después en la misma
avenida
aquí lo que vemos en un circulito es el
único carruaje tirado por caballos que
quedaba en ese momento el que se hizo la
fotografía 13 años han pasado desde la
foto de los caballos hasta las fotos de
los automóviles algunos quieren utilizar
esta imagen para enseñarnos con mucho
acierto como la tecnología puede ayudar
a resolver un problema habíamos resuelto
el problema de la caca y empezábamos con
el problema de los gases aunque en ese
momento todavía no lo sabíamos esto es
un salto tecnológico que se llama de
cero a uno un salto fundamental en la
humanidad a partir de aquí el motor
térmico
casualmente gracias al start eléctrico
comenzó a imponerse al vehículo
eléctrico y todo lo demás es historia
entonces hablamos hoy en día de que en
esta década va a ver una transición
igual con el automóvil térmico al
automóvil eléctrico que el automóvil
es el que nos va a salvar pero esto es
un poco tramposo y tramposo perdón yo
voy a decir porque pues básicamente
porque han pasado cien años entre media
vivimos en una sociedad pegada al
automóvil y en el mundo hay 1400
millones de coches de los cuales 250
millones de coches están en europa de
los cuales 28 millones de coches
aproximadamente están en españa así que
antes de hacer esta revolución también o
al mismo tiempo tendremos que ver qué
hacemos con todo esto y con todas las
necesidades que hay asociadas a estos
automóviles entre ellas también por
supuesto todo lo que está asociado el
empleo así que por eso digo que esta
comparación es un poco tramposa porque
no aquí lo empezamos de cero tenemos que
redefinir completamente el automóvil y
la movilidad para hacer esta transición
hacia la descarbonización es decir dejar
de utilizar el petróleo como combustible
y estamos hablando del coche eléctrico
que en el estado actual del arte de la
tecnología tenemos una comparación que
es bastante impactante con las baterías
que tenemos hoy en día para mover un
vehículo eléctrico aproximadamente
necesitamos 31 kilos de batería para
tener la misma energía que contiene un
kilo de gasolina fijaos si hemos estado
dopados como civilización utilizando el
petróleo y fijaos si tenemos un reto
y mucha inteligencia que meter para
sustituir al combustible serían 37 kilos
de batería
si hablamos de gasoil y no hablamos de
gasolina así que básicamente si nos
queremos mover en un coche eléctrico que
sea equivalente a un automóvil actual de
gasolina lo que necesitamos es una
batería que pesa aproximadamente media
tonelada 400 500 caballos y sabéis qué
es eso pues otra vez un caballo ya
estamos con el caballo otra vez
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo
cuando nos movemos con un coche
eléctrico es llevar un caballo andaluz'
o un caballo árabe de media tonelada ha
subido a nuestro coche sólo que este
caballo ya no suelta nada por el tubo de
escape este caballo sólo pide la alfalfa
pero no las nueva procesa y la suelta y
es muy eficiente a la hora de procesar
la energía con lo cual buena parte de la
ineficiencia de la densidad energética
de las baterías las recuperamos gracias
a la eficiencia del motor eléctrico pero
fijaos que estamos hablando del
automóvil eléctrico y de la movilidad
eléctrica y no tenemos solamente que
centrarnos en los coches y ahora empiezo
con las buenas noticias es que la
movilidad eléctrica es mucho más y el
coche eléctrico paradójicamente que
estamos hablando que nos puede salvar de
una porción importante de las emisiones
de co2 lo que ha empezado a hacer ya
solamente el coche eléctrico es a
limpiar las ciudades en esta imagen que
tengo aquí detrás tenéis a pekín en un
día sin contaminación y un día con
contaminación
china es el paroxismo de la polución
urbana exactamente el mismo problema que
teníamos con los humos en los tiempos de
los caballos y aquí esto se ha hecho
posible gracias a la electrificación
pero no sólo gracias a los coches
eléctricos si china ha conseguido todo
esto en sus ciudades es básicamente por
las bicis eléctricas por los scooters
eléctricos y en nuestro entorno los
patinetes son muy importantes también
una de las gracias o de las cosas
importantes de la electrificación
justamente es que nos permite separar
muy bien y hacer una forma de movilidad
mucho más adaptada lo que necesitamos
para que queremos mover un coche para
hacer 10-15 kilómetros y lo podemos
hacer con un scooter con una bici en
todo caso la buena noticia es que hoy en
día hay tanto dinero y tantos cerebros
puestos en desarrollar nuevas baterías
para automóviles y con la batería de
electrolito sólido de aquí a 10 años
vamos a conseguir con este esquema que
parece tan sencillo y tan fácil pero
básicamente eliminando el líquido de la
batería y poniendo un electrolito sólido
resolver muchísimos de los problemas que
tienen las baterías mucha más autonomía
mucho menos peligro de incendio mucha
más velocidad de recarga la
electrificación
un problema lo que se refiere al
automóvil el problema es todo lo que
viene de atrás y realmente el mensaje es
pasar del automóvil normal al automóvil
eléctrico no es pasar de 0 a 1 como fue
pasar del caballo al automóvil pasar del
0 a 1 es tener en cuenta todo este
esquema que tengo aquí a mi espalda
siempre estamos hablando de emisiones
siempre estamos hablando de polución
pero el verdadero reto no es hacer un
automóvil que sea cero emisiones de co2
ya sea un coche eléctrico ya sea un
coche de hidrógeno o un coche con un
combustible neutro en carbono
usando hidrógeno y co2 captado de la
atmósfera todo eso va a venir el reto
justamente está en que todo el ciclo de
producción de algo tan básico como un
automóvil sea respetuoso con las
emisiones y tenga un balance cero desde
que extraemos los materiales de la mina
hasta que reciclamos el automóvil hay
que hacer un zoom hacia afuera en la
fotografía del automóvil para tener una
visión realmente revolucionaria de lo
que puede aportar siempre ha sido como
un motor económico el motor económico
del coche cómo vais a ver va mucho más
allá de lo que es producir coches y
movernos con coche y la revolución está
justamente desde antes de utilizarlo
hasta después de utilizarlo solo con
esta foto estaremos haciendo una
verdadera revolución con
usted el automóvil y todo lo que viene
aparejado como estáis viendo esta es la
foto apropiada y por supuesto la gran
pregunta y la gran cuestión es y qué
pasa con toda esta gente es decir si nos
vamos a ver con vehículos que tienen
cero emisiones cómo vamos a hacer para
que todo el mundo tenga acceso a este
tipo de vehículos esta foto que os pongo
aquí siempre la uso no es de ningún país
exótico es españa es la provincia de
barcelona es mi ciudad cornellà uno de
los sitios con mayor densidad de
población de toda europa en españa
tenemos un problema muy importante y es
el problema de que por estructura social
y económica tenemos muchísima población
agolpada en las ciudades y estas
personas no se pueden quedar atrás lo
bueno es que antiguamente no se podía
elegir el coche eléctrico hoy en día que
hemos enseñado es el patinete es el
metro es el autobús es el automóvil
también la cuestión es tener sistemas de
movilidad inteligente y ahí es donde
entra la conectividad y que estemos
todos conectados y que tengamos las
opciones de poder utilizar medios de
transporte colectivos o privados este es
un debate súper interesante para poder
movernos es como que ese halo de
libertad que ha tenido el automóvil
porque era el único medio de locomoción
que teníamos en el pasado
se está perdiendo gracias a todas las
opciones que tenemos hoy en día pero
justamente situaciones radicales y
extremas como la que hemos tenido hoy en
día han vuelto a poner en boga lo
importante que es también el transporte
privado así que lo tenemos que hacer de
una manera inteligente e inteligente
significa aprovechar mejor que nadie la
conectividad para organizarnos es un
momento en el que tanto se re pensé en
las ciudades tanto habrá una revolución
en el mundo de la locomoción ya más allá
de lo que es el automóvil
tenemos más buenas noticias no solamente
el automóvil va a cambiar la forma de
propulsar se si lo que vamos además
hacia el automóvil inteligente no
solamente porque se conecta con nosotros
e interactúa sino también porque va a
ser capaz de moverse por sí mismo lo que
os contaba del nivel de 3 de conducción
autónoma que es eso bueno los niveles de
conducción autónoma se miden de 1 a 5 y
justamente el punto 3 en el que estamos
empezando ahora mismo estamos en la
orilla como diría calzada es el momento
en el que el coche tiene la
responsabilidad de lo que pasa en la
conducción empiezan a aparecer los
primeros automóviles que en autopista
cuando tengamos un atasco nos vamos a
poder poner a mirar el móvil una
película eso si 58 segundos no más de
momento pero esos coches ya se pueden
comprar como lo hacen pues con una
propia tremenda de sensores con radares
con lidiar con ultrasonidos y por
supuesto con cámaras y con visión
artificial
estos coches tienen la capacidad de
conducir por sí mismos pero esto
obviamente tiene un coste que hay que
digerir y ese coste va a ir reduciéndose
de una manera radical durante los
próximos años y esto va a ayudar también
a que la movilidad con el automóvil sea
mucho más fácil para todos aquellos que
no puedan abordar el coste
de comprar un automóvil de este tipo un
automóvil conectado fijaos una cosa yo
me gustaría hacer una reflexión siempre
se habla de que el automóvil es la cosa
más ineficiente del mundo y es verdad un
coche pasa el noventa y tantos de su
vida útil aparcado tirado en la calle
parado en cualquier sitio pero amigo ese
5 ese 3 ese 2 por ciento de utilización
del coche que nos permite ir a donde nos
da la gana cuando nos da la gana sin
ninguna limitación y sin siquiera pensar
en la energía que utilizamos para
hacerlo es lo que ha hecho que sea un
producto tan increíblemente exitoso y
que ha proyectado a la humanidad al
nivel al que estamos ahora entre otras
cosas poniendo su granito de arena su
granito de arena así que es muy
importante que lo que sea que venga se
acerque bastante a eso porque si no
entonces tendremos un problema más grave
de movilidad como hemos visto antes si
no somos capaces de resolver los
problemas que tenemos a la hora de
organizarnos como sociedad en las
ciudades y esto implica por supuesto
gestionar muy bien la energía la energía
libre de carbono es una oportunidad se
ha hablado de esto en esta reunión esta
mañana y creo que no me tengo que
extender mucho con ello porque está más
que explicado y justamente todo el mundo
hoy en día
lo importante y la oportunidad que
tenemos con la economía verde pero
fijaos me gustaría llegados a este punto
voy a daros una primicia mundial aquí
como siempre yo tengo que traer noticias
frescas os traigo una primicia mundial
os voy a enseñar en exclusiva tenemos
muchísima tecnología tenemos muchísimo
avance tecnológico
tenemos muchas disrupciones fijaos que
si habéis ido siguiendo el hilo de lo
que voy contando lo que le está pasando
a la industria del automóvil es que
estamos pasando de una industria del
automóvil basada en la ingeniería
mecánica era la dictadura de los
mecánicos sobre la industria del
automóvil que abre el foco que trae
nuevas energías y que traen muchas
tecnologías de conectividad y de
ingeniería electrónica informática que
antes no estaban dentro de la industria
o sea lo que hace básicamente es
nutrirse de novedades tecnológicas para
incorporarla todo está más abierto y
todo está más conectado y comunicado que
nunca y es ahí hacia dónde vamos pero
llegados a este punto os quiero traer
una exclusiva también
para que veáis hasta donde hemos llegado
el camión
conectado el camión autónomo y un cambio
al 100% eléctrico que tiene una
capacidad para moverse como no tiene
ningún otro camión con unas cargas
impresionantes queridos amigos ante
vosotros el camión del futuro
también eléctrico del futuro ahí lo
tenéis se llama tren y ya existe
con esto podemos transportar montones de
mercancías toneladas y toneladas de
mercancías de una manera completamente
verde y está completamente
infrautilizado así que una vez que hemos
volado y lo hemos dejado volar la
imaginación vamos a poner los pies en el
suelo y también vamos a ver de qué
manera podemos utilizar de manera mucho
más eficiente lo que ya tenemos como el
camión eléctrico por ejemplo y así de
esta manera conseguiremos avanzar e ir
mucho más rápido para que la industria
del automóvil ponga su parte habéis
visto la película contact supongo que si
un padre que estimula la inteligencia de
su hija aficionados a la astronomía en
un momento dado la hija le dice papá hay
vida ahí fuera en el universo y papá le
dice pues seguramente es hija bueno me
lo estoy inventando pero más o menos el
mensaje es ese pero desde luego si no la
hay cuánto espacio desaprovechado esto
es españa desde el cielo de noche esta
foto es más o menos tramposa
cuanto más acercamos el luz zoom más luz
hay cuanto más lo alejamos menos luz hay
pero precisamente en nuestro país
tenemos una oportunidad que es también
repensar cómo queremos organizarnos como
sociedad porque este sistema de
acumulación soviética en el que hemos
vivido desde los años 60 un sistema en
el que básicamente lo que hemos tenido
es una migración de la gente del campo a
la ciudad para
a trabajar a la fábrica se ha terminado
ahora somos una sociedad conectada y de
servicios así que es el momento
igualmente de volver atrás y ahora ya no
tenemos la fábrica como centro de
producción ahora se trata de ir de la
ciudad al campo para producir energía y
para estar conectados si conseguimos
hacerlo el automóvil el automóvil
eléctrico de hidrógeno el automóvil con
combustible sintético será mucho más
útil para nuestra sociedad y nos dará
muchas más soluciones que si nos
empeñamos en seguir congestionando nos o
sea que no solamente hablamos de avances
tecnológicos y de repensar las cosas
sino que hablamos también de volver a lo
que tenemos y utilizarlo mejor y para
terminar
después de todo este viaje os tengo que
decir que el automóvil es responsable o
mejor dicho la automoción en general
porque el automóvil privado ni siquiera
del 25 por ciento de las emisiones de
co2 que hay a la atmósfera en el planeta
tierra si pasado mañana consiguiéramos
eliminar todos los coches térmicos si
pusiéramos coches eléctricos habríamos
resuelto una cuarta parte del problema
nos quedaría el 75 por ciento así que
depende de nosotros conectar todos estos
sistemas que los que hemos estado
hablando para hacerlo más eficiente y
poderoso y que no acabemos descarrilando
en la misión de hacer que el automóvil
tenga su parte también porque justamente
el automóvil técnicamente va a estar
preparado mucho antes de lo que está la
infraestructura para podernos aportar
esta solución y una petición final está
mía personal yo que ya soy un poco de la
vieja escuela me gustaría que el día de
mañana que esté pasado mañana como
estáis viendo esto no es fantasía es la
realidad sea lo que sea el automóvil que
sigamos teniendo esa oportunidad esa
parcela de libertad esa parte de él que
quiera conducir un coche que pueda
hacerlo aunque no sea propiedad de
alquiler por horas como sea que pueda
hacerlo y que pueda ir donde le dé la
gana cuando le dé la gana
si hemos solucionado todos esos
problemas y hemos mantenido este factor
diferencial del automóvil entonces
habremos triunfado muchísimas gracias
amigos hasta la próxima
[Aplausos]